I got the screenplay and was deeply
attracted to the subject matter and the
significance of it and it just was one
of those scripts I don't know what
happened sometimes you get a script that
has a little voice in it is it sitting
on your desk going do me you know this
was one of those projects but in fact my
daughter alerted me then to the novel
because she saw the script on my desk
and said dad the book thief are they
doing a film about that and and I said
yes they're offering me a role and she
said are you gonna play death because
everyone in my house is a casting
director you know they know my
repertoire they know my tendencies and I
said no it's this really beautiful role
so she told me that all her friends had
read the book when they were in year 10
because it did by default without
intention become a young adult little
and I thought that was remarkable for
this subject matter and she said you
know this book oh my god because that's
what most teenage girls start their
sentences right she said this book
changed my life
and I was deeply impressed that she'd
used the word book and but the fact that
they changed their lives and I wondered
what the alchemy was in this story that
would make it so potent for an audience
I actually read the book a month ago
so the book was really useless when I
was shooting I just based myself on the
script well because I had nothing else
no but I really loved the book but he
was a bit you know it was it was
different because I've already seen the
movie at that point so when I'd read the
book I would kind of read myself
well not myself and you know I would see
myself as Lee's all right see Jeffery is
Hans and then I would sort of read a dog
commander
me of the whole shooting but I think I
still think it's a huge and it's a
fantastic book but it looked like I've
learned the next time if ever I do a
movie based on a book I'll still read
the book before starting to shoot a
unique postmodern child the photos on
the cover of the book when I was that
age I was getting up in front of the
class in year eight strumming a tennis
racket miming to the Beatles the book
was my Bible it was a great reference
manual you know because in the script
and I think it's a terrific adaptation
and I hope the fan base are not upset or
disappointed because they haven't messed
it up by changing the ending or merging
characters it's a pretty good
compression of 580 pages into a hundred
and the bulk of the narrative is in very
very good shape so I had lots of yellow
post-it notes all through the novel that
reference those particular scenes that
were in the film because hounds is not a
particularly verbose character I might
only have three or four lines in a three
or four page script scene but I could
always go to the novel and find 20 pages
of interior monologue and great
metaphors and colorful language that
would give you something else to bounce
off and that was really wonderful you're
working with two people who are very
distinguished Emmy winner Oscar winner
and Emmy winner and Tony winner and you
have to I imagine that even if you
haven't yet had a chance to catch up
with all the great things that these
guys have done you know that they're
pretty big deals was it intimidating to
go over to work with people like this at
the beginning I have to say the first
day I thought I was shooting with Emma
Watson and I got really happy
like my first like big movie and bling
with Emma Watson and then they said it
was Emily Watson and I didn't know who
she was but then I watched war horses
and she was really fantastic and sorry
but I had no idea who he was either and
even now if I mean my friends are gonna
come and say so who are you playing with
I'll go Jeffrey rush I'll say who's that
I'll say well he's what he's Captain
Barbossa in Pirates of the Caribbean so
the guy in Pirates because they only
know that but but I've heard that
apparently he was a good actor but then
I watched the shine and obviously he his
performance really blew me away and I
thought he was fantastic and he did a
phenomenal job in that I think the
important thing that and the most
difficult thing is to find somebody
who's right to play that in that
character at that age I did a I think
one of props help me get this film was I
did a short round about 2001 or whatever
which called the Power Girl which I got
my first BAFTA for and that was for the
13 12 13 year old girl and I think that
sort of helped because the idea is
really you know
Sophie's remarkable in just the amount
of technique she's got but normally kids
their age don't have an office because
they have not the life experience to
sort of to learn the technique to know
to hit the marks to to dull that spatial
awareness so it's it's a case of finding
someone who's on it was as close to in
this case lethal as we possibly could
and you know we had a huge search and it
probably seen about a thousand across
the world 3 continents thousand
different people sort of taped or came
in for auditions and I find it you know
if we if we choose the right person then
we if you've got someone who's got
enough character
then it makes my job a lot easier it's
mace but it really allows me just to
sort of to set them free and to guide
them through what we're trying to do be
yeah I think it makes for a moment real
in a more natural performance I wouldn't
dare
paternal eyes or choose to mentor
someone from whom I knew I was going to
learn the tremendous amount because I
tend to be I suppose from a theatrical
background I feel myself you know so
he's one of those people who and I've
seen it in older actresses that I've had
the pleasure of working with whether
it's Cate Blanchett or Kate Winslet or
whoever they draw the camera into them
and let them let let the camera see the
internal contradictions mysteries the
silences within inside a character that
may not even be in dialogue and I know I
tend to be a little bit of a kind of
late eighteenth-century steam-driven
piece of industrial machinery puffing
and panting away trying to project
something from my intellectual analysis
of the script so it was it was a
glorious journey and thankfully you know
we didn't have an onset drama coach
putting us through bonding exercises
because I would have punched them in the
head it happened very organically and it
started I think with Emily and myself
being aware of looking out for her
initially you know first day shooting
thinking there's a lot of people now and
it's the pressures on it's different
than mr. lazaar she's carrying 97% of
this film and it just felt like that
wasn't necessary to be you know but we
we we actually by default I suppose the
weather was so cold we were supposed to
start shooting on the backlot and do her
arrival into this into the Hoberman
household which probably would have been
a good way for all of us to start but
the paint was freezing on the back lot
set and peeling off so we had to go into
the kid
in a studio and that was good to find
the domestic hub of Hanson roses
marriage and their relationship and then
what would it be like for this
grief-stricken illiterate motherless
girl to come into if I've given her any
kind of accidental advice it's been for
me acting is a state of imaginative play
we used to be called players remember
now all credits went up the players have
fun and she's always said that in
interviews I did the audition for fun
and I said write a book about acting for
fun it's a great stand my age I don't
know if when I get older there I'm gonna
but my agent at school we don't learn
about the Holocaust
I remember reading and a suitcase in
sixth grade and that was it so when I
did the movie I had to do a lot of
research I remember watching all these
movies like Schindler's List life is
beautiful the pianist's the boy in the
Striped Pyjamas the reader and yeah and
also I think it was great that it was
shot in Berlin because everywhere you go
there's always these walls or these
posters saying what happened at these
different places and also I went to see
the Berlin Wall and some bomb shelters
so that I could learn a little bit um
and also I went to see the movie two
weeks ago with my best friend and she's
actually quite smart and she didn't
understand everything and then it showed
to me how people in kids my age well our
generation don't know enough about what
happened and that's why I think you know
some people think it's knowing that we
keep on making these movies but I don't
think so because you know all the the
camp the main camp survivors are gonna
die you know at some point and they're
not gonna be alive soon and then I just
hope really in a hundred years that
people remember what happened well first
of all not to let it happen again and
you know sort of
for a way to remember the people that
died and to remember the people that
fighted for it
so I just think it's really important
that we keep on making these movies
because my generation I have practically
no idea what happened so I really hope
that in 100 years we still have these
new movies on what happened so that you
know we keep on you know people keep on
knowing what happened it's a huge part
of history yeah yeah
[Applause]